bonjour à tous alors effectivement comme
l'a dit dit evans j'ai fait des études
d'expertise-comptable et je vais vous
raconter aujourd'hui comment mes études
d'expertise-comptable ont eu un impact
sur mon régime alimentaire actuelle
effectivement des études
d'expertise-comptable comme ça on peut
pas se dire que la comptabilité et
l'alimentation
ses proches en fait je vais essayer de
vous démontrer qu'elle en fait ya qu'un
pas entre les deux depuis toujours je
rêve et j'ai rêvé de créer des
entreprises une entreprise et pour ça en
2006 quand j'ai passé mon bac après il
s'est posé la question de l'orientation
et j'ai tout de suite pensé à perdre et
l'expertise-comptable pour justement
pouvoir apprendre à gérer à tout en
matière économique le business model
tout ça et puis j'ai fait ma licence mon
master et en 2010 quatre ans après pour
des raisons personnelles il a fallu que
je reprenne l'exploitation agricole
familiale en gestion il ya deux
personnes formidables de la production
sur place ont fait des bovins des
céréales les céréales qui servent à
alimenter des bovins en fait tout ce
qu'elle peut plus classique et moi ça
m'a laissé du temps pour apprendre ce
nouveau cette nouvelle vie suis je
deviens du jour au lendemain
l'heureux gestion je m'occupe de la
gestion pas gestionnaire mais je
m'occupe de la gestion de d'une petite
exploitation
donc on est on est on a on a cette
chance d'avoir une petite parcelle sur
cette grosse boule et il faut la faire
sa grosse boule de terre il faut la
faire fructifier pour que les
générations futures puissent en
bénéficier
et du coup ces deux personnes qui
travaillent avec moi sur l'exploitation
me laisse du temps pour la gestion la
commercialisation et pouvoir penser à
tout ça
et puis j'ai commencé à rencontrer
quelques éleveurs à parler avec eux
rencontrer leurs familles
on a commencé à discuter et puis je me
suis rendu compte de la réalité
économique
j'ai fait des études
d'expertise-comptable la réalité
économique agricole m'intéressait il
faut savoir que quand on achète un bovin
canton m'acheter un bovin avant et bien
c'est un cours
et puis si jamais mon prix de revient
est au dessus de secours et ben tant pis
pour moi c'est pas de bol c'est le jeu
et du coup c'est quelque chose qui m'a
les par mois j'ai appris à l'école que à
l'école d'expertise-comptable ça t'a
coûté 1 tu fais ta marge et tu revends
et là c'est pas le cas et en fait
c'était quelque chose qui était
incompréhensible pour moi je pouvais pas
comprendre qu'on puisse perdre de
l'argent le matin en se réveillant parce
qu'on travaille on travaille dur et là
tout ça commençait à trotter dans ma
tête je me suis dit bon il faut que je
fasse quelque chose faut vraiment faire
quelque chose à côté de chez moi il y
avait des des ventes à la ferme de la
vente directe des produits locaux ça
trottait et puis en parallèle il y avait
des crises alimentaires vous avez
entendu parler des lasagnes au cheval
moi je suis juste à cheval sur la
traçabilité c'est tout ce que je connais
du cheval en fête
voilà et du coup je me suis retrouvé à
voyager et puis j'avais fait un stage
pour apprendre le métier d'agriculteur
pendant deux mois dans une exploitation
houzé des agneaux et puis au bout de
deux 2 ans en 2012
j'ai décidé de réaliser mon rêve de
m'épanouir et créer ma société et du cou
allez on y va on ans sa société
on va faire de la vente directe du
producteur au consommateur avec des
produits
de qualité tout ça produit à moins de
200 km on achète au consommateur au
producteur pardon un prix juste on ne
négocie jamais avec lui on revend aux
consommateurs un prix juste aussi tout
le monde s'y retrouve
puis je vais travailler avec bat johanna
vite j'ai fait mon stage on à faire des
agneaux des on a fait des agneaux et ben
voilà on va vendre aussi des agneaux
marque un producteur juste à côté de
chez moi qui fais des ports et puis
stéphanie qui fait des supers voilà
juste à côté du court voilà tout est
centralisé à 50 km autour de chez moi
qu'ils soient les productions l'abattage
et la découpe l'impact local commence à
être en moi assez important et puis
après je me dis tiens ce type qui sont
quand même formidable
j'aimerais bien que les personnes à qui
je vends ma viande puisse les rencontres
et plus les connaître du coup on va
mettre une limite géographique on ne
livrera jamais à plus de 200 kilomètres
entre le lieu de production et de
livraison s'est inscrit noir sur blanc
et puis
là je me dis cette idée elle est quand
même pas mal
ah la vache c'est quand même vachement
bien stylé du coup on va en faire le nom
de la boîte c'est pas mal on a commencé
à vendre ça a plus assez développé et
puis moi je continuais à sourcer des
producteurs toujours locaux toujours
dans les 50 km je continue à écouter
leurs leur vie avec passion leur métier
et là je me dis mais ces types là sont
vraiment formidables c'est ce que je
disais et du coup j'ai commencé à
vouloir leur racheter leur production
donc ça pouvait être aussi bien des
pâtes puis est un producteur de savon
puis est un type qui fait des brosses à
dents et puis voilà il ya un peu de tout
dans ma région à moins de 50 kilomètres
de chez moi et ac j'ai commencé à me
dire mais c'est quand même formidable
j'habite à paris j'ai la chance de
pouvoir avoir d un pied en normandie et
du coup je commence à consommer un peu
une fois de temps en temps des produits
locaux et là je me dis qu'il ya quand
même quelque chose de sympa je connais
exactement quand je me lève le matin je
me brosse les dents je sais qu'il y
avait ma brosse à dents quand je mange
mon muesli je sais qui a fait mon muesli
café le fromage blanc qui s'est ralliée
mon musée et ça pour tous les repas et
en fait je me suis rendu compte que très
simplement en octobre 2015 ya neuf mois
je me suis dit tiens si je me mettais à
ne manger uniquement 100% que des
produits locaux bon à 80% du temps parce
que je tiens quand même à avoir une vie
sociale et je tiens quand même à pouvoir
sortir avec mes amis et à boire une
bière entre temps en temps du coup je me
suis lancé dans ce projet de ne
consommer que des produits locaux et en
fait ça ça m'a permis d'avoir un
leitmotiv qui est que je tiens à ce que
à connaître l'histoire de la personne
qui a créé ce qu'ils sont en train de
manger ces personnes là ont une vie et
il faut remettre le producteur au coeur
de notre circuit d'alimentation
savoir ce qu'on mange ça c'est un
message qui est très important pour moi
et après c'est comme ça que je vous
prouve que manger local à moins de 200
km c'est facile c'est faisable
vous pouvez faire tout mon peuple faire
il suffit d'être un peu organisés et de
chercher un peu et on peut consommer
localement et de manière responsable et
tout en rémunérant dignement tous les
intermédiaires de la chaîne et voilà
comment mes études d'expertise-comptable
ont fait mon régime alimentaire
aujourd'hui voilà merci beaucoup